truppenbesuch von
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
in der steiermark nach der musikalischen
begrüßung und einer kurzen einweisung
wird offiziell ein dekret übergeben
oberst ärztin doktors ingrid meyer wird
die kommandantin das sanitätszentrum
sind gemeinsam mit dem steirischen
landeshauptmann informiert sich dann
aber megawatt ajo steiermark über die
dort stationierten pandur radpanzer
grenzübergang spielfeld informieren sie
verteidigungsministerin und
landeshauptmann über den stand in sachen
grenzschutz wir sind nach wie vor zweig
und berlin im einsatz
unverzichtbar wir von der vertreterin
von dem vertreter nach der polizei
bestätigt worden ist und die grenzen zu
sichern um die maßnahme die auch in
besonders behördlichen zusammenhang
notwendig sind durchgehend 24 auch durch
landeshauptmann hermann schützenhöfer
betont die wichtigkeit der in der
steiermark stationierten hubschrauber im
bezug auf katastropheneinsätze wie bei
der schneekatastrophe 2009 10
ganz wichtig was würden wir tun wenn wir
die nicht hätten verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner nützt das pressegespräch
für eine ankündigung die pandur
radpanzer werden aufgestockt
die militärische landesverteidigung und
insbesondere die sicherheit unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten im in und
ausland das allerwichtigste ist